when Stefani is back on set of the voice  much drops electrons to me I'm somewhere  do you talk to me 46 year old singer  joined her former coaches on the show  Tuesday to debut her new single misery  and seemingly pointed at boyfriend Blake  Shelton while she belted out the song et  had eyes inside the taping the couple  was spotted chatting and Blake whispered  in her ear in between takes Gwen got a  well-deserved standing ovation from not  only the crowd but all of the current  judges including her man the no doubt  alum also shared the pre-show happenings  on her snapchat and it looks like she  and sons kingston an apollo rode to work  with her beau  you